reactions gotta love that song
lin-manuel Miranda put his favorite
founding father on the map with that
Broadway hit it was called Hamilton we
know all about it but what about some of
the lesser known characters from the
Revolutionary era well the author of a
new book argues that one in particular
deserves to be remembered a doctor and
signer of the Declaration who championed
progressive causes that remain topical
today Benjamin Rush was first of all
sort of the founding father that people
haven't found yet but author Steven free
thinks it's high time America did with
good reason he had very quietly helped
write the proclamation that set off the
Boston Tea Party he had written one of
the first major abolition writings
and basically was in two years of the
Continental Congress coming to
Philadelphia he was in the Continental
Congress and he was signing the
Declaration of Independence at the age
of 30 the good dr. rush this is the good
dr. rush freed spent five years writing
his biography having at his disposal
Russia's own autobiography and Diaries
housed at the American Philosophical
Society in Philadelphia he writes in
about the year 1774 a certain Thomas
Paine arrived in Philadelphia so this is
rush beginning to tell the story of how
he met Thomas Paine who was just a local
writer they talked about writing about
independence which rush considered to be
a very dangerous thing to even write the
word independence but he actually
decided that he would encourage pain to
write the pamphlet about independence
that he had already started when the
pamphlet was done rush convinced him to
call it common sense so all of this
would have been served here at the
tavern the doctor dined here at City
Tavern with his much more famous
co-conspirators John Adams Thomas
Jefferson even George Washington so how
pivotal would you say dr. rush was to
the American Revolution
I would say first of all that I think
that everything he did is
so far not really well understood but I
think that the key to the American
Revolution is that all these people work
together
people forget that when Jefferson was
writing the Declaration of Independence
rush was writing the Declaration of
Independence for Pennsylvania and each
state was declaring its own independence
so this was a group effort but he was
one of the few signers of the
Declaration who in fact rushed to the
front lines what's wonderful is that
he's there talking to Washington the
night before they're about to cross the
Delaware and he writes about all this so
a lot of the way we know that Washington
was holding a little slip of paper that
said victory or death is because it's in
Russia's Journal after independence was
won rush refocused his fight against
slavery how much of slavery impacted his
legacy well interestingly so he wrote
one of the first of the founding father
writings on slavery against slavery
he owned a slave for about ten years
after the war we have really no idea why
there's been speculation that he bought
a slave because some abolitionists
bought slaves to free them I couldn't
find enough evidence that that's why he
did it to say that the abolition
movement kind of stopped during the war
it picked up again in the later 1780s
when it did rush freed his slave but for
all of his influence in the precedent
rush hasn't found celebrity the way some
other founding fathers have should lend
my well of written to Hamilton about
rush about right absolutely rush was a
much better more interesting person than
Hamilton
[Music]
if he wants to come back to do rush rush
was so much a part of the founding of
the helping of the founding of the black
church in America that he could do rush
in gospel
I think rush was a better person I think
if you asked Hamilton he would have said
rush was a better person every person
who comes to rush says why isn't this
guy more famous what I found out in
looking at not only his writing but what
happened after he died is that there was
a concerted effort to keep what was most
interesting about rush from the public
why well John Adams and Thomas Jefferson
had written rush some of the most
incredibly personal letters they ever
shared with any of them hundreds of them
so rush was kind of the founding father
who knew too much his legacy was sort of
slowly quashed part of it is because
Rush had an interestingly contentious
relationship with George Washington he
didn't want his family to know that he
and Washington had had this thing what
was that thing at the very lowest ebb of
the war in the early 1778 some of the
generals were talking about whether
Washington was making the right
decisions in who he was deputizing as
his generals and he wrote an anonymous
letter to Patrick Henry in which he
mirrored some of these arguments it's so
exciting in a way because you think of
it as like an email you shouldn't have
sent because he actually sent Patrick
Henry this letter in January he asked
him to burn it he and Washington then
kind of made up and Patrick Henry sent
the letter to Washington two months
later I don't know what it did to
Washington except but it made him mad at
Rush and he remained upset with rush
about this through his life these
combination of things led the family to
try to make sure that the most
interesting things that Rush wrote that
people didn't see that rushes true
legacy thrives here this is the famous
surgical amphitheater of Pennsylvania
Hospital his passion was personal his
son John descended into mental illness
after killing his best friend in a duel
and was treated here for decades late in
his life rush wrote another public
letter saying these are the things we
need to do to dramatically improve care
for the mentally ill so he brought the
fact that John was there into the pub
into the newspapers because he was so
intent on advocating for the rights of
the mentally ill for their diagnosis for
their dignity and for a lack of
discrimination against them for Steven
freed resurrecting the most significant
founding father we've never heard of is
more relevant now than ever there's a
reason they used the phrase more perfect
union no one thought it was perfect and
part of what I love about Rush is
writing he's really trying to point out
the things about America they're gonna
be hard racial prejudice having science
and religion live together having
liberty and good government live
together and so he wrote about these
things in a way that I think is still
thoughtful today and makes you realize
that these issues are hardwired into the
American experiment which we are still
in and you really got a thing about this
he was a true accidental founding father
because you know people don't realize
that when the Declaration the last stop
was Pennsylvania
Philadelphia and the original guy who
was supposed to sign it refused it was
too dangerous and so then Rush said I'll
do it I'm in for respect it I gotta tell
you this is I'm reading this book it's
fascinating it just keeps being involved
in more and more interesting things when
the yellow fever gripped Philadelphia in
the 1790s he was one of the few doctors
and stated treated teeth stayed and
treated people lost his sister yeah
amazing life and fascinating book